Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
If I sound really bad, then yes, I know.
My voice is still not recovered yet, so today will be a short stream.
But, I want to pursue Lu Bu.
Apparently, I was this close to finally pursuing Lu Bu.
And I was like, I'm going to do it this week.
I'm not canceling Dynasty Warriors again!
Because for some reason, every time I cancel a stream, it's Dynasty Warriors.
And I was like, okay, it'll be fine.
It'll be fi- We're gonna- We are gonna pursue that Lu Bu!
Finally!
It only took four streams to finally pursue him.
Oh my god.
So yes, if I have to, we just stop after pursuing him.
But, like I said, I still want to stream for you guys.
I think after the Marvel Rivals Tournament, I will take a little bit- I will take two days off just to see if my voice heals a little bit and my cough gets a little better.
Because tomorrow, I do have a VTuber Rivals Tournament.
And it starts at 8am.
And then there's a Day 2.
So Day 2 will also start at 8am as well.
So that's why I was like, ah, fuck.
I usually have a rest day on Sunday.
But this time, I don't.
So I can't rest on Sunday, but most likely rest on Monday and Tuesday.
Also, I will be in the Disguised Toast VTuber- Not VTuber, sorry.
Disguised Toast Marvel Rivals Tournament again.
I just got invited, I think like two days ago.
And I dragged Surefour in with me as my other player.
Because I was like, oh yeah, it was possible.
Could I not have four to five support players on my team again?
I was like, oh my god, thank you so much for the invite.
I just have one thing I want to make sure.
Is it okay if I'm a support main?
Yes, I know, I got top 500 as support.
But it's really rough.
It was really rough for me last time.
I really appreciate it if I could have players for each of the roles.
It would mean so much.
And then Tess was reassuring me that don't worry, it'll be different this time.
I won't have three to four support players.
Not three to four, more support players on my team.
And he also asked me who I wanted on my team.
And he gave me a list of people who were already in the tournament.
And I saw Surefour was in the tournament.
Toast was like, okay, get someone that's around Eternity level.
Because I'm categorized as Celestia, thank god.
When I saw, because he gave me the player list.
Because it's not going to be randomized, by the way.
The tournament for Toast this time, it's next week.
By the way, the tournament is next week.
So like, it's going to be soon.
And then they're like, okay.
I saw and he's like, this is not going to be randomized.
So you can bring one duelist with you.
And I was just like, can I bring Surefour?
Because I'm technically Celestia.
Because I looked at the people they put as Eternity.
And I was like, there's no way.
I play as good as these people.
That are categorized as Eternity.
Because they're all like, ex-pros.
And I was like, there's no fucking way.
I was never signed in a tier one org.
There's no way I should be categorized as the Eternity player on my team.
I would feel so fucking bad.
Especially because the teams are not randomized.
I was like, can I be Celestia?
Please, can you categorize me as Celestia?
And the duelist was like, no, that's cool, it's fine.
Yeah, yeah, you're gonna be categorized as Celestia.
I was like, oh, thank God.
I was like, oh, thank fucking God.
Because I saw one person in that list.
I was like, that was categorized as Celestia.
And they were like, they were also a one above all support player.
And I was like, there's no fucking way.
If he can be Celestia, I should be Celestia.
I saw that, I saw that name.
I was like, there's no fucking way.
If he's Celestia, I should be Celestia.
I fucking fought against him in ranked all the time.
There's no way.
So I was like, that was my heart.
It's like, yeah, no, we are categorized as Celestia.
Oh, thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Yeah, so like, I was like, oh, thank God.
I was really happy about that.
I was really thankful too.
I'm really thankful to get another invite.
It really is a big opportunity.
I'm really happy that, you know, people are inviting me to these things.
So thank you so much to Toast for the invite.
I really look forward to next week.
The only person I know that's on my team is Shur4r because I dragged him into the tournament.
And then my rest of the teammates are going to be randomly assigned and stuff.
So we'll see.
I don't know who my teammates are, so we'll see how it goes.
Yeah, my voice is really fucked right now because I've been coughing the last week.
So basically, I'm at the puberty stage right now.
So that's where I'm at.
I hope Monday and Tuesday, it'll get a lot better.
I've just been perpetually sick the last year or so.
Eventually, it'll get better, right?
Eventually, right?
I can't be sick forever.
Oh yeah, by the way...
Um...
The Marvel Rivals devs personally reached out to me.
And that's all I can say.
Alright, also...
You guys, during tomorrow, you're going to notice that I have a lot of Marvel Rivals currency.
But I didn't pay for it.
How did I obtain that currency?
I don't know.
So, maybe I can actually finally own skins?
God,
I love free stuff.
Uh...
Anyway...
Because you guys are going to see my currency on the top right tomorrow.
You're going to be like, what the fuck, Doki?
I thought you said you were never going to spend money on Marvel Rivals.
I didn't though.
I didn't spend money.
It's going to be a lie.
If you're going to see that, you're going to be like, what the f- I haven't spent any yet.
But you're going to see it, and then you're going to be like, what the f- I haven't spent any of it yet.
I don't know.
I haven't used skins in so long.
I haven't used any skins in a long time.
So, I was like, what skin do I even get?
Like, I hate the Luna Snow skins.
Personally, I'm not a fan of any of the Luna Snow skins.
So, I was like, none of them I really want to buy.
So, I was like, I don't know what to buy.
Even the new one?
I don't like her hair for the new one.
I think everything looks great, except for the hairstyle.
I'm not a fan of the hairstyle for the Luna Snow skin.
So,
yeah, that's why I'm like, I don't know.
And then you're like, oh, what about the new skin that just came out?
What was it?
Magic and Hulk.
I don't play Magic or Hulk.
That's the thing.
Like, a lot of them, I don't play the characters.
So, it's like, what's the point of spending my free money on characters that I don't play?
I'm going to see them on other players.
So, yeah, I don't know.
I'll figure it out.
Or maybe I'll just hoard it.
I'll hoard my free money until then.
Anyway, it's Dynasty Warriors.
Oh, yeah.
Dad update.
Today, I walked Dad today.
Oh, my God, I'm sorry.
I'm breathing heavily because I'm sick right now.
So, I'm at the breathing heavily stage because I talk too much.
Dad update.
I was walking, you know, as usual.
I was walking Dad.
And, you know, he was being...
Okay, so, this is just going to be a really short story.
But in the elevator, I walked Dad.
And obviously, you know, I was like, alright, elevator.
You know, let's go to the elevator.
And then there was a very pretty lady in the elevator.
A very pretty blonde white lady in the elevator.
And he freaked out.
You know what I mean by freaked out?
He, like, instantly, like, went up to her and was, like, whimpering.
He was, like, and, like, trying, like...
Like, he was, like, jump...
Like, not jumping, but, like, you know, he, like, jumped up to his legs and was, like...
And I'm, like, dude, every...
I was, like, you don't do that to me.
I was just, like...
That's a me.
That's a pretty lady.
And then, like, the girl was just, like, aw.
And I was just, like, please touch me.
I was just, like, you...
I haven't seen him whimper or, like...
I haven't seen him whimper like that in so long.
I was so...
I was, like...
I was so surprised.
I was, like, oh, my God.
Like, you fucking whore.
You whore.
I can't believe it.
Anyway...
Yeah, he got a little too...
And his tail was wagging so much and everything.
And I'm just, like...
Oh, my God.
Restrain yourself.
Restrain yourself, Doki Amber Doge.
We're in public.
We're...
Anyway...
That's my Doki Amber Doge story for today.
Alright, let's pursue Lupu.
Which one is it?
I believe it's this one.
It has to be that one.
And he's neutered, by the way.
I don't know where he's getting this testosterone.
He's fucking cut off his balls as a kid.
But, who knows how much longer it'll be around.
Alright, hello.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
He has a secret role?
What?
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
I'm supposed to be left side Doki.
Give me a sec, guys.
Where is left side Doki even?
I don't remember.
Is it this one?
No, that's centered.
Nope.
Where is left side Doki?
Okay, there we go.
Left side Doki.
I need to rename this.
Who are you, really?
Okay.
Whenever my voice gets better, I want to do a super long stream of this game.
I don't even think we're like 30% done.
Oh, wait.
That's me.
Wait, he knows who I am.
I'm the Guardians of Peace.
Oh, I'm an assassin?
Pretty fucking shitty assassin.
They all see my face and then they fall in love with me.
Wait, but if I'm like here for peace, then why am I killing people?
Unrecognized.
I'm like the fucking Forsworn brother.
Wait, is this why I'm running out of history?
No!
They wrote me out of history!
Peace suits, man.
They deleted me!
Wait, she knew too?!
It's fucking over.
She already lied.
Oh my gosh, he kidnapped Diao Chan?
I will never be able to turn Diao Chan back into the girl she once was.
This cannot be her real lore.
This is like the first time I heard that Diao Chan is actually a fucking secret assassin.
Out of like nine other games.
I was like, she was never a fucking... what the fuck?
She was supposed...
She was just to be like, hot.
She was just supposed to be really, really fucking hot.
There's no way.
It was very well hidden.
She's not real in the first place.
She's real to me!
How dare you.
She's real to us!
My waifu is real.
And I'm going to need your help.
That's funny, they're like... she says all this and then she ends up marrying him.
What, burning down your fucking village?
Everything you've done for me, like killing my entire family.
Also, JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
24 hour stream of this game when you're recovered.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I want to do like six plus hours of this stream whenever I get better.
But thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Antai, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
CP, I think they miswrote pieces.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they do take a lot of like artistic liberty with the game.
But like, I'll still play the game regardless.
I'm going with you, I want to do it.
Where's the no option?
Okay.
Yes, where's the I would like to walk away?
Okay, I'm going with you.
I need to ask Yura and give them more money.
If I want to say no.
Why are you?
Why am I waiting?
Hello, Cao Cao.
Now he's a fucking child.
He's a Bishimen.
I know, it's just so- I think it's the first time I've seen him without like a beard.
It's so weird, he's just like Liu Bei, but evil.
Alright, assassination of Gan Jue.
Alright, it's time!
Wait, actually, let me double check really fast.
If I haven't- wait, what weapon am I using right now?
Okay, the Crim- yeah, I heard the Crimson Orchid was strong.
Uh, I want to make sure that I have everything I want to use.
Okay, alright, I'm ready.
It's time!
We are finally- we are finally pursuing Liu Bu!
I'm ready!
I'm fucking ready.
I will come humbly before you.
Hmm...
I have but one question.
Are you loyal to the Han?
Or to Dong Zhou?
You are very forthright.
I feel many men have lost their heads for answering wrongly.
Answer already.
Oh, it's just like a what-if situation where like, we just killed- Cao Cao just dies.
They just kill him.
And then like, we just- it's just the cute two kingdoms.
And this is?
Diao Chan is my name.
You understand me well, Cao Cao.
I'm inclined to accept.
Oh!
I mean like, don't they have guards?
Oh my god!
Okay, not gonna lie.
There's so many guards out there.
Like, I feel like they would have like, seen her pull the fucking- Oh my god, there he is!
Liu Bu!
I shall pursue you.
Oh shit.
Is she hot?
You can't kill her, she's your future wife.
Wait, he does look like Liu Bu.
Wait, he basically looks like Liu Bu, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
They have the same fucking face.
Little bro.
Hey, that's my big brother, Liu Bu.
Alright, wait, that's how I'm pursuing him?
Alright.
I'm- I'm- Wait.
Wait.
Guys, all his attacks are- Guys.
Okay, I- I'm going to run.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
All his- Oh, wait a minute.
Why- Why is all his attacks red, guys?
Guys.
Why are all his attacks red?
Wait, I cannot dodge any of them?
Wait, what- What do you mean?
Okay.
Guys, I don't know if I win though.
And his invisible red armor.
He should totally pursue it.
Okay, guys, I'm a little worried.
I have a feeling that maybe I cannot pursue him.
But like, I can't tell yet, guys.
I can't tell.
Oh my god, oh my god, he's coming.
Oh my god, oh my god, he's right behind me, guys.
Oh my god.
Be cautious, Liu Bu is approaching.
Oh my god, oh my god.
He's coming, guys.
Oh my god, oh my god, he's right behind me.
He is, isn't he?
Guys, is he right behind me, guys?
Oh, fuck.
Guys, guys, I think he's right behind me, guys.
Oh my god, oh my god, I can't- I think he's right behind me.
Oh, I can see him right now.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Okay, let me look behind me real fast.
Okay, okay, we keep going.
Okay.
I thought you wanted to pursue Liu Bu.
Why are you running?
Oh my god, did you not see what he just do to me?
What do you mean?
Yes, everything was unblockable.
How do I kill something I can't fucking block, guys?
What do you want me to do?
I can't kill things I can't block.
Oh god.
He just died.
Okay.
Alright.
Just don't get hit.
Wow!
That seemed so fucking easy.
Okay.
Okay, we can- We'll redo the fight.
First off...
I can't beat the shit out of you while getting closer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where do we go?
He's right behind us.
Guys, I'll- I swear, I'll swear, guys.
I swear I'll totally pursue him.
I swear to god.
Oh, it's this one.
I swear.
Oh no, oh no.
He's coming.
Oh no.
He's right behind us.
Oh my god, Cao Cao, quick.
Quick.
He's literally right behind us.
Oh my god.
He's in the palace.
JK, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cao Cao, please.
Please.
He hit me twice and I almost died.
You know, I thought I'd have, you know.
I thought I could like, survive like, five hits.
But like, he literally hit me two times and I was ready to fucking just die.
Like...
Ancient Chinese generals and your pure mirror are closer than they appear.
Thank you for the super chat, Miyazaki.
Thank you.
Where's this guy?
Zeon, thank you for the super chat.
Since it would be funny for you to try to fight him.
His attacks are mostly blockable.
When an officer's entire body glows red, it's an unblockable.
Together with Lord Wang Yun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, I saw that.
But then there was like, two unblockable attacks.
Like, he did two unblockable attacks on me.
And then I was like, yeah, nevermind.
And then I have no more buttons after that.
I don't know.
Be careful.
How is he already here?
I'm still trying to fight this one guy.
Oh no.
Are you okay?
He pursued you?
Let us cooperate.
If I can be of help, then I would be happy to.
I didn't expect to be able to pay you back so soon.
Oh no.
Oh my god, I see him in my rearview mirror right now.
Oh my god, Cao Cao.
Cao Cao, please.
Stop fighting Cao Cao.
Get over here.
Oh my god, he's glowing.
Oh my god, there's a red aura.
He's in my rearview mirror, Cao Cao.
Oh my god.
He's coming over.
Cao Cao.
Oh god, he's right there.
Bro, who's walking next to me?
Oh god, I don't think I can kill him.
I don't think I can kill him, guys.
I am very scared.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, it's a Zhang Liao!
Okay, not gonna lie, as a little bird, I had a crush on Zhang Liao.
Oh shit!
Wait, he's gonna fucking kill me.
I'm not even gonna die to Lu Bu, I'm gonna die to his other general.
Okay, but like, as a little bird, I won't lie, I had a crush on Zhang Liao.
This guy.
I thought he was so cool.
What the fuck, how did I get on a horse?
Oh shit!
Oh my god, my heart rate is... it's not good.
My heart rate is going up, and not because I still have a crush on Zhang Liao, but like, I'm actually gonna die.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Okay.
Why do I accidentally kill my horse?
I'm like panicking, so I'm actually...
Oh!
No!
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm literally like 1 HP right now.
Okay.
Okay, there's a bun.
There's a bun.
Oh!
That was so scary.
I'm...
I...
Oh my god, thank god.
I don't know, he was just so cool.
I just thought he was so fucking cool.
Him and Zhuge Liang were like my crushes in Dynasty Warriors.
Okay, open the door.
No, that's okay.
That's okay.
Everything is okay.
I...
I might be like really fucked up right now.
Because like, you know...
I don't have any HP, but that's okay.
That's alright.
I don't need HP.
As long as Lu Bu is not on me, that's fine.
Wait, I think I went the wrong way.
Where am I supposed to go, guys?
I don't know, what am I...
Wait, am I supposed to be here?
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Am I supposed to... wait.
Where am I...
Wait, is this the right way?
Oh, he's right there.
Wait, he's right there.
Oh, see the yellow flag.
Okay.
Okay, I'm a little worried right now though.
About like, my team.
Because Lu Bu is nearly right there.
And I'm a little worried.
Pursue him?!
I have no buttons!
What do you mean pursue him?!
Like, I'm actually... I might die.
I might die.
I have no buttons at all.
Oh my god!
I might die to a regular man!
Wait, he's...
Oh no, he's fighting downtown!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
Guys, it's over.
Wait, this is...
Oh my god!
Please!
No!
Oh my god!
He's so strong!
What the fuck?
Okay, you know what?
Let's fight Lu Bu.
You know... Oh my god, I'm so close.
Okay, guys.
We're going all the way from the beginning.
I'm gonna fight Lu Bu.
I'm gonna do it.
I can...
Oh shit.
What the fuck?!
I'm gonna do it!
Oh god.
I'm gonna do it.
I almost died, but...
Oh my god.
What is wrong with you?
I'm gonna do it.
Oh my god, perfect parry!
What?
I can do it.
I'm dead.
Okay.
I can do it.
No, no, no.
Look at that.
Look at me go!
Whoa!
I lasted...
Guys, I lasted 47 seconds.
I think that was pretty good.
Guys, I...
I...
I lasted 47 seconds, guys.
I think that's...
I think...
I think that was a pretty good record.
It's okay, I can do this.
I...
Okay.
Oh my god!
Did I not die?
Holy shit!
This is it, this is it.
I can do this.
Oh, shit.
Oh, the jump.
Okay, this is it.
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
My last bun!
I don't have any more buns!
Guys, look at that!
Look at the amount of damage I do!
He has a bow?!
Guys.
How come he has a bow?
Yep.
Why the fuck...
Okay, okay.
I can do this.
It's like he brought a fucking gun!
Who's looking at a...
Oh, fuck.
I...
I can't dodge this.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
That's not fair!
He, like, brought a fucking bow!
Okay.
Like, how do I parry it?!
How the fuck do I parry that?!
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Nice!
Another parry!
I just need one more parry.
Nice!
Oh my god!
I have one bun left!
This is it.
Jesus Christ!
Bye.
What?!
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, I don't think I can pursue Lu Bu, guys.
I...
Guys.
Sometimes retreat is the answer, guys.
Sometimes...
Sometimes it's okay to run away, guys.
Sometimes it's just...
Yeah, you know what?
I'll take...
I'll take 53 seconds.
Guys, I'll...
I mean...
Guys.
All I'm saying is that...
I don't think any of you guys can last more than 53 seconds against Lu Bu.
Come on!
Don't lie to me!
You really think you can last longer against the Lu Bu?
Oh my god, he's coming.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
This is tactical, okay?
I...
We tried.
Our record was 57 seconds.
I beat him there?
Oh, I didn't know we were lying today.
I didn't know today we were gonna fucking lie.
Can Chow Chow die so I fail?
Equivalent exchange.
You know what?
That's fine.
Okay.
Let's just get him out of here.
Come on, he's so close.
Oh my god, he's coming.
I see him in my rearview mirror, guys.
We gotta leave.
We gotta fucking leave.
I see him on my rearview mirror.
Goodbye!
Please!
Oh shit.
Please, let me through!
Please!
I don't wanna deal with him!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, get out of here.
Okay, that's cheating, man.
You have, like, shields.
Like, I have Lu Bu on my fucking tail right now.
Guys, what is the button to call my horse?
Can I keep accidentally pressing it?
Is it this one?
Oh, okay, it has to be this one.
Nevermind, I figured it out.
Okay.
Let me make sure we kill him.
Nice.
Okay, Chow Chow, I guess you'll just watch.
Like, always.
I keep accidentally pressing my horse button for some fucking reason.
Alright, let's go.
We gotta kill Dong Min.
Man.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Look, we're not thieves here.
We just wanna make sure we don't die to Lu Bu.
Thank god the red hair is not here yet.
Thank fucking god.
Oh my god, I'm just lucky the red hair isn't chasing us.
We would have already been dead.
Oh, come on.
I know about the staff.
Please.
He's in my rear view mirror.
It's like Jurassic Park all over again.
Let's go.
We gotta go.
What is the strongest weapon anyway in Dynasty Warriors, guys?
Oh, I fucking know.
I'm fucking scared.
I can only last 57 seconds against that man.
I don't think I wanna fight him.
Okay, nice.
Locked.
The spear?
Wait, is the spear actually the strongest?
Oh shit.
I know Lu Bu's approaching.
I know he's coming.
Nice.
The AK-47.
Next boss.
Oh, the Shu Yong.
It's not about how strong it is.
It's absolutely about how strong it is.
You think Lu Bu's weapon...
He chose that weapon because of how cool...
I mean, it does look pretty cool.
But it's also one of his strongest weapons in ancient China.
I mean, he's lucky.
He has the bonus of it looking very fucking cool.
Toki, what you gonna do?
What you gonna do when Lu Bu comes for you?
I don't know, die?
I'm thinking of the super chat.
Simple thing to think, yeah.
Like, what else can I do?
All I can do is fucking die.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Wait, how is he already here?
Cao Cao, no!
Cao Cao!
Run!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
Get out of here!
What are you doing?
Fucking, we gotta go!
Cao Cao, we gotta go!
Cao Cao, no!
What are you?
I was here!
Oh my god.
That was fucking scary.
Like, what is he doing here?
Nice.
I wish Jenny was here.
Where the fuck is Jing now?
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, he's over there.
Guys, I do not think I can fight him.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, I would love to fight him.
Guys, we have tried.
I don't even think he knew I existed in that one fight.
I think that was the worst part.
Like, I barely existed for that man.
Okay, I didn't...
Guys, it wasn't even two times.
It was actually three times.
Like, I think it was four times.
It happened so fast that you guys think I...
You guys forgot I did it four times.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Chao Chao, please.
I'm trying to kill him.
Oh god, thank god Chao Chao fucking ate a bread.
Oh no.
I'm trying my best.
Oh god, Lupo's killing all of them.
Okay, nice.
Nice, Chao Chao.
We're almost there.
Okay.
God, fucking nerds.
Please.
Wait, wait, is he behind me?
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Chao Chao, Chao Chao, Chao Chao, please.
Chao Chao, please.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, I'm gonna use this.
Chao Chao.
He's right behind us.
I'm trying my best.
There's so many shields!
Oh my god, how many fucking shields are there?
He's literally right behind us.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, this is so obnoxious.
Oh my god, Chao Chao, yes!
Thank god!
Oh, thank god.
Thank fucking god, get over here!
Oh my god, he's right there!
Oh my god, thank god.
Oh my god, he was right there.
He was right there.
He almost got me.
Oh my god, he almost fucking...
If he, like, poked me once, I'd be gone.
I'm so god.
Oh, save.
The Xiaohun family saved me.
God, it felt like I was in Jurassic Park.
I was driving the jeep and I see Lu Bu in the rear view mirror.
I...
I swear to god, it felt like I was in that car.
He just wore it in a nipple.
Holy fuck, that was scary.
That is actually so scary.
I thought, like...
They always say do not pursue Lu Bu.
But what do I do when he pursues me?
Like, what do I do?
Usually, it's the other way around.
They never warn you of what you do when he starts chasing you.
Uh...
I think I see a way to follow me.
I will make it mysterious.
Follow me.
That night.
Oh, he trusts me.
It's okay, I can get it later.
Yeah,
why are you here?
Where were you when Lu Bu was chasing me?
What do you mean you were gonna be here when I needed you?
I was screaming my fucking lungs out.
Where were you?
And Lu Bu doesn't?
Bro, that guy brought a fucking gun to a fight.
I'm finally pursuing the hero.
Thank you so much, chat.
Tao Tao the hero?
Damn.
I mean, he did win in the end.
Yeah, let's trust Tao.
Yeah, guys.
We all know Tao Tao is the most trustworthy guy out there.
I trust him.
The winners are heroes.
Yeah, guys.
We all know Tao Tao's history has been marked with honesty and trust.
Just like how Guan Yu really trusted Tao Tao.
And lived to old age.
Right, guys?
It was nothing really.
I don't want to tell people I had help.
All of them think I'm awesome.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Of course not.
I don't know.
No, fuck Yao Chen.
Don't be a fucking simp, Tao Tao.
She's gonna get married like three to four different times.
She's gonna fuck Liu Bu.
I sleep now.
Oh my god, why am I dreaming about her?
I don't want to pursue her!
Stop!
She's not the only woman in this game!
There's other women in Dynasty Warriors!
I should have choices!
Name them.
You know, the other women that's gonna show up later in the game.
Name one other woman in Dynasty Warriors.
You know, the child.
But obviously not her.
I'm not gonna name her, guys.
But there's other mature women later on in the game, guys.
I swear to god!
Kills without companion wrecks havoc across the land.
His countless sins have proved enough of his unjust, bestial nature.
It's time we act, answer the Emperor's call, gather our troops, and put an end to this evil.
The veracity of this edict matters little to the Lords awaiting this moment.
We excuse to unite their forces to begin their march to Luoyang.
Like, you know...
Oh my god, they're all kids, too.
They're all children or wives of the other generals.
So, like... Guys, I swear to... Oh my god.
Okay, so there's Zhuge Liang's wife.
There's Cao Pi's wife.
There's...
There's Zhang Fei's wife and daughter.
There's Guan Yu's daughter.
There's...
I'm trying to think of one that's single!
I'm trying to think of the single ones!
Okay, why all the wives?
Those aren't names.
Diao Chan is technically a wife, too!
She's the wife of Dong Zhuo, Lu Bu, and one other guy.
If Yuan Shao can make up for that by leading the coalition, it's a small price.
Just one name, Doki!
Name one woman!
What am I?
What are you trying to do?
This isn't Fortnite!
Why are you trying to set up a trap for me?
Right!
We'll strike them down together!
The die has been cast.
All that remains...
Just give us one name!
Just name a woman!
Guys!
Come on!
Come on, guys!
What are you trying to say?
Chen... Wait, what's... Oh my god, what's the flute lady?
What's Cao Pi's fucking... What's Cao Cao's son's wife's called?
Chen Ji?
Oh, you love women?
Name one.
Come on, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, see?
Chen Ji!
I remember her!
Because she used a flute to whack people.
Look at that!
Our name!
Chen Ji was pretty hot, too.
She was.
But she's also taken.
And also, like, much younger.
Because she's literally Cao Cao's son's wife.
So, like, she's basically Sun Shan Xian.
So, like, that's, like, sort of, like, that's iffy, guys.
That's iffy.
I'm trying to find women that are not children!
Guys!
Alright, let's see.
Ready to go out.
Oh, she was 20?
Oh, it's, um...
It's the axe guy.
Oh my gosh, she's 20?!
Guys, we have a chance.
We have a chance, guys.
Yes, Yan Wei!
Guys, we're safe.
She's 20.
Oh, she's 10 right now.
Oh, guys, I was joking.
I was testing you guys.
Oh, wait, that's bad.
But she's only 20 later.
Guys, I am not waiting!
That is so...
Guys, what the fuck is...
Guys!
You can't just beat DL Chan!
Yikes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
There has to be other women!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I'm gonna...
Guys, I'm gonna make some tea, guys.
Guys, I'm gonna make some tea.
I'll be right back.
It's also not my fault, okay?
The early...
The early Dynasty Warrior games...
They had, like, four women characters you can play, okay?
And it was Chen Ji, Sun Shen Qian, Yao Chen, and then the wild one.
You know, the one in the jungle?
That girl.
I don't remember her name.
But there was, like, actually...
And then they added more, but I already forgot their...
And then, oh yeah, the Qiao sisters too.
Okay, the Qiao sisters were cute.
I love them.
I love their, like, fans as weapons, guys.
And then I forgot all the other ones.
Yeah, the Zhudong girl.
Hello, guys.
Yu Ying?
Isn't Yu Ying Zhuge Liang's wife?
Yeah, but she was, like...
Okay.
Okay, I'll talk about her.
But, like, her literal character description is that she was so fucking plain.
And people couldn't believe Zhuge Liang married her.
Because she was, like, technically ugly.
And then, so, like, they made her design so fucking average.
Because they're trying to be like, yeah, she's ugly.
Look at how boring her design is.
And that's why I could never remember her.
Because, like, but she wasn't ugly.
Like, she wasn't ugly in the game.
It's just that they made her design so fucking average.
That she wasn't memorable.
Because in the story, she's supposed to be really ugly.
But really, really smart.
And then people were like, why did you marry her?
She's so ugly.
But then he's like, I don't care about how she looks.
It's all about her mind.
That's literally, like, that's literally her story.
Chang Kong is here.
Who the fuck cares about Chang Kong?
Like, they added him later in the game.
So I could never, like, I never, like, saw her as memorable.
Because her design was just so average.
They made her so hot, though.
To be fair, everybody.
Pang Tong was supposed to be, like, super fucking ugly, too.
But then they, like, they're just like, okay, instead of making him ugly, let's just cover him in clothes.
Because they don't know how to make ugly characters except for Dong Zhuo.
Except for, like, Dong Zhuo.
That's, like, the only guy they made ugly.
Until now.
Okay.
I am not sure.
Then you have my grat...
Then you have my gratitude.
Gratitude.
He's, like, a fucking traitor.
Yeah, he's a fucking snake.
Okay.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Using fans as weapons.
I guess a Chong Kun could make a good cannibal.
100%.
That's why they're so chonky.
They're, like, that...
No, they're, like, the...
In Lord of the Rings, you know, the giant...
The...
The giants they use.
Okay.
You guys can't deny it, but we're 100% the fucking villains in Lord of the Rings.
Like, if we were, like...
Like, a faction, we would be the...
You know, we would be, like, the swordsmen.
The Sauron faction with the giant fucking trolls that walk around.
So, like, the Chong Kuns would be that.
Like, the giant trolls just walking around.
And then, like...
Oh, 100...
Yeah.
You know, like the...
You know the Lord of the Rings RTS?
I love the RTS game of the Lord of the Rings RTS.
I wish they did a remaster of that game.
I would, like...
I played that game so much when I was growing up.
The...
The Lord of the Rings RTS game.
We would definitely be the Sauron...
The Sauron...
The Sauron faction.
The battle for Middle-Earth.
Yeah.
Yeah, there is!
It was one of my favorite RTS games.
That and Starcraft.
It was so fun.
I always played the Sauron faction.
And the...
The evil ones.
Because the evil ones have the cool...
Have the cool minions.
Have the coolest units.
I don't think they have, like, a remastered version of it, though.
If they did, I would play it.
Because I love that game.
Are you sure we'll be able to?
Because the bad guys always have the coolest designs.
Who the fuck would want to play as humans in Lord of the Rings?
Why the fuck would I want to be a man?
With a bow?
When I can be a goblin with a bow.
Riding a fucking dog.
Okay.
Alright, Hongi.
But Erigando!
Yeah!
But I could be a Nazgul!
On a dragon!
Erigan walks on his feet!
Yes, I'll walk!
The Nazgul rides a fucking dragon!
Okay, I'm not going to ask about the child.
Where's Sun Jian?
Oh, they're like introducing each faction to me now.
Well, I obviously don't care about the red faction.
And there's Cao Cao's faction.
I'm going to join Liu Bei's just for Zhuge Liang.
Just because he's hot.
I'm only doing it for him.
He is my Three Kingdoms Oshi.
And I want to see Pantong die for the 10th time.
He doesn't join until the end?
That's why I'm playing the long game.
Doki, why?
After everything we went through...
He's hot.
I don't think I can.
I'm sorry, my heart is already taken by Zhuge Liang.
I'm sorry, Cao Cao.
He is my only Oshi in this game.
He has been my Oshi.
He has been my Oshi since Dynasty Warriors 2.
I have spoken.
If you say so.
Alright, I'll do what I can.
Look, there's only one of me and so many of you, guys.
Calm down.
Calm down, everybody.
Why am I walking with him?
Fade to black.
You must be our commander.
I'm proud to be serving you.
We're a varied bunch.
Some of us are well-versed in the martial arts, while others just came from sowing the fields.
But we're all the same in wanting to make the world a better place.
Just the two of us.
We look forward to your command, sir.
Okay.
Oh my god, is this it?
Is this Hulo Gate?
Oh, I have a squad!
Squad!
We have a squad now!
So do I- Wait, do I have better weapons?
Level 80.
Oh, I have a level 80 sword now.
Nice.
Level 80 sphere.
Oh, wait.
Level 91.
Oh, the red rush staff.
Okay, we're still gonna get the- Apparently, the Crimson Orchard is still the best one.
Wait, do I have a stronger attack?
No, they're all the same.
Yeah, okay.
We don't care about the other horses.
Also, we don't care about these.
Oh, where's my squad?
How do I- How do I use my guards?
Unleash a vol- How do I use them?
How do I use my fucking team?
Okay, I don't even know how to use my fucking team.
Oh, wait.
I have offerings.
Wait, what?
Oh, I don't.
I thought that was my offering.
Okay, wait.
I wanna see if I have any romance options yet.
Alright.
Alright, what are my- Do I have anybody that wants to talk to me?
Let's see what your reputation is like these days.
Oh, Xiaodun?
Okay, Hanover.
Wait, what?
Mediation possible?
Oh, I can- I can improve my bond?
I have to fucking pay- I have to give him money?
Oh, skip my training.
Okay, where's my training with him?
Bro, what the fuck?
Is he gonna be my escort?
Like, what?
I was like, what?
Why do I have to pay him?
Okay, while in rage form, what do I need?
Using a po'dowl.
Okay, I can use a po'dowl.
Okay, let's see.
What- Where is the- Okay, 89.
That's fine.
I just need to use rage and charge.
I need you to touch this with Lu Bu.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, in rage, charge attack.
I don't use a charge attack.
I don't remember how to use a charge- I'll figure this out.
I'll figure this out.
I can do it.
Alright, Dong Zhuo.
Is this a gate?
Is this Huluo Gate?
Oh wait, no, it's not.
This is not Huluo Gate.
Oh, hold it down.
Okay.
We're located just outside of Luoyang, where Dong Zhuo resides.
Zishui Gate is one of the barriers protecting the city.
Two enemy officers guard the gate, Li Ju under the command of Dong Zhuo and Huluo Xiang, a warrior widely renowned for his sheer might.
The only way is through them.
I want all of your forces working together to achieve this goal.
Guys, do I fight Lu Bu here?
Please don't tell me I fight Lu Bu here.
Please, guys, I don't think- Guys, please, I'm not ready, guys.
Please.
Guys, guys, I don't- Oh, thank god.
We are in the superior of the enemy- Oh, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
I don't think I can- I don't think I can do it.
Guys, I'm not ready.
Guys- You mean to place me in the rear guard?
I mean, you ain't shit.
Glory is my right birthright.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, this isn't Hulao Gate.
This- This isn't Hulao Gate.
I'm not ready.
Your pedigree is completely useless on the field of battle, in this petty officer- official's opinion.
You impotent!
That's enough, you two.
I'm not ready, guys.
I'm not- Well, I'm not trained.
I'm not trained enough.
Everyone will have a chance to prove their valour in the battle to come.
You have all been notified of your positions.
It will be up to each of you to read the battlefield and decide the best course of action here.
Then, our choices will make all the difference.
Oh no, I'm gonna get Shahoodun as my companion.
What the fuck?
Oh wait, I can have Guan Yun?
Okay, but Shahoodun is cooler, guys.
He's cooler.
He still has two eyes.
Okay, and he'll be even cooler when he has one eye.
He is already cool with two eyes, but imagine how cool he will be with one.
Guys,
I'm trying to remember how to do charge attack.
Guys, it's not working.
Guys, the charge attack isn't working, guys.
I don't remember how to do charge attack, guys.
How do I charge it?
I'm coming for that big charge.
Oh, hold Y.
Oh, I was holding... Okay.
I was not holding Y, guys.
I was holding... I was holding everything.
I was holding X.
Was that noticeable?
Was it noticeable that I wasn't holding Y?
Jesus Christ.
This guy is so strong for a fucking petty officer.
Jesus, why is he so strong?
Why?
Oh my god, I used like all my bread.
Oh, wait, what?
Where is he?
Oh, shit.
Oh, guys, I'm stuck on the tree.
Don't worry, I'll save you.
Okay, but first I gotta kill this guy first.
Oh my god, bro, you're fucking... I'm gonna... I can't.
Guys, I'm gonna pay him $4,000.
I'm gonna pay the relationship therapist.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm gonna pay the relationship therapist $4,000.
I don't think I can do it.
He gets my 4k.
He'll fix my... He'll fix our relationship.
I believe in him.
I just don't understand.
Don't worry.
He'll fix our relationship.
I believe in him to fix my relationship.
There we go.
Don't worry, Sujin.
Eat your bread.
Okay.
I got you.
Wait, Pan Fen and Yun Fu has been... Bro, I can't fucking... There's so many people.
Oh, no.
Not the morals.
I don't know why I used the arrow.
I'm trying to... Oh, I don't have enough allies.
Okay.
I'm so confused.
I was like, what do you mean?
Okay, my coalition fucking sucks.
Not gonna lie.
Use the order... That's what I was trying to do!
Oh, Hanzo, please.
I'm trying my best to save every... I'm one man!
Okay.
Bro, I just killed seven officers.
What do you mean number alone is not enough?
Oh, my god.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Who needs help?
Okay, we need help.
Oh, please.
I am getting there as a... Please, old man!
I'm getting over there!
I killed so many people!
Please!
Eat your buns!
Eat your buns, everybody!
Oh, fuck.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Alright, that's fine.
Everybody, keep eating your buns!
Guys, please!
It's one of me, everyone!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry, Guardian!
Eat your buns!
Arrow!
What do you mean?
I'm like right here.
Oh, god.
Okay, nice.
Oh, my god.
Why are all my generals so fucking bad?
They're at point D.
Look, I'm going to the closest point, guys.
These guys need to eat buns, too.
I'll get there eventually, guys.
Guys, there's a line.
There's a line for the Guardians of Peace, guys.
Oh, my god.
Please.
There's a fucking line!
There's only one match for peaceful resistance!
Okay, nice.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we might have to...
Oh, okay, Guanyin's dead.
Okay, my bad.
My bad.
Okay, Guanyin might have died, guys.
He died early.
Eat your buns, guys.
Everybody.
Oh, shit.
Lupe.
Okay.
Oh, we lost Shu!
It's the romance of the two kingdoms now.
Oops.
We just lost the entire Shu army.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's actually... What do you mean there's not even two brothers?
Only one brother left.
I guess I am the last brother, everyone.
History has changed.
Whoops.
Oh, that's awkward.
Yes, there's only one brother.
And where's the...
Wait, where's the... Wait, did they all die to one man?
Wait, they all died to one guy.
There's three of them.
Wait, what?
They all died to one guy.
Okay.
Alright, that's not my fault, guys.
There was literally one man.
Like...
And he... He didn't even have a name, guys.
He didn't even have a name.
Doki don't understand.
He had the power of the morals.
But it was one man!
Guan Yin is supposed to be the god of war!
Okay, nice.
Come on, get out of here.
Get out of here.
This is a fucking gangbang right now.
We're all here to fucking kill you.
Okay, we got everything.
This should be... Are you all happy now?
Are you all happy now?
We lost you, but you guys are all happy, right?
Oh god, they're all so low.
Their HP is all so low, guys.
Okay.
That's right.
Send that arrow in!
That's fucking right!
Get over here!
I am a one man army!
I'm gonna fucking kill you!
I can't kill Lu Bu, so I guess I'll kill you.
I'm gonna pretend you're Lu Bu.
So I can feel something.
So I can roleplay and think I'm better.
Please take the time to aim your...
No, I'm gonna beat him up into my arrows, guys.
Okay, nice.
Wait, I have rage mode.
I'm gonna use it for this one person.
Just for this one guy.
This guy that obviously is not that important.
That's fucking right.
I need to kill some people, too.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
That's right, look how fancy this is.
There's nobody here to kill, but I look so cool.
That was pretty cool, right guys?
That looked pretty cool, right?
Okay, I don't trust the people up top to kill them.
Oh my god, is our morale okay now?
I'm fighting my demons, guys.
I'm just fighting my demons.
Nice.
Gotta kill him now.
Well defended, I just fucking beat the shit out of him.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here, well defended my ass.
Good job, Shalujan, you did nothing, but you look so cool.
Nice, it's mine now.
Our morals are so high.
I believe in us.
Let's go!
Me and my two kingdoms, there was never a third kingdom.
What do you mean a third kingdom?
There was never a third kingdom, guys.
It was always just Wu and Wei.
Okay.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
Started a duel?
Wait, what?
How?
Who fucking dueled me?
What?
Fight!
Wait, I can do a 1v1?
The fuck is this?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Wait, that's so cool!
Guys, do you think he's gonna win?
Guys, I think he fucked up.
Guys, I like how everyone's like, yeah!
You got this!
You're so- You totally got this, commander!
Yeah, I don't think he's got- I like how they're just all surrounding me!
Everybody was just surrounding me!
That's so fucking funny!
Wait, how do I start another duel?
I wanna start another duel!
Challenge me!
Nice.
Thank you!
Challenge me!
Oh shit.
Wait, how do I- Wait, how do I- Oh, are y'all- Oh shit!
I couldn't tell where my spearman was!
Wait, change characters!
That's right, I wanna be cool!
That's fucking right.
Wait.
Oh my god!
Wait, can I challenge him?
No, I can't challenge him and Xiaohu died!
I'm gonna be angry!
That's fucking right!
Oh!
God, I'm so fucking cool!
I'm so cool!
Behold!
God, I wish I- Honestly, the only thing I wish was that- I wish I could just play these guys instead.
Because like- Oh my god!
That's me.
Oh!
Oh shit!
I just killed 400 people!
That's like my only gripe about this game.
Is that I can't play as Xiaohu Dun.
That's like my only gripe.
I wish I could play as the other characters.
Because I- Oh my god!
They look- Oh my god, they just look so fun!
Yeah, we did it!
I don't know what you did.
What is he doing?
Like they're- It was just one guy.
Bro, he used all of that for one guy.
Oh my god, beat him up!
Beat up the one guy!
It's just him!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, bro!
What the- Duel him.
I'm dueling him.
That's right.
Oh, really?
Really?
Yeah, I think he's like the last remaining officer anyway.
I'm pretty sure.
Of this entire army, he's the last one left alive.
Bro, the fact that like- The fact that like he used that attack for this one guy was pretty fucked up, not gonna lie.
Area 51 raid.
We did it.
Yeah, there's like no one else left.
It was just him.
He was like, I might be the last man in this army, but I won a 1v1.
Okay, nice.
And slam your- Okay, I don't think I can- I'm gonna pay to win.
I'm gonna pay our relationship therapist to fix my relationship with Shahoodun.
Nice, plus 46.
Ooh!
Conquer bases 5 times.
I killed 12.
What'd I do?
Collapse 2 times, defeat foes with using a sword.
Okay, cool.
Oh, I can upgrade this now.
Wait, I can have arrows?
How?
Wait, how do I use arrows?
Wait, what?
I could've used arrows this entire time?
Oh, it's a battle art.
I was like, where's my arrow?
I could've just pulled a gun.
Who's your jinn?
Who's this guy?
Why did Lu Bu was the one who challenged you?
Ooh, I'm fucking dead.
We all know that.
I'm dead.
Zero, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like,
there won't be a 1v1.
He's literally like 10 men.
And we're guilty of it too.
But the way we've dithered the whole time, it may no longer be possible to defeat Dong Zhuo.
Only 10?
Hello!
Don't you think Yuan Shu crossed a line back there?
Lord Sun Jian has every right to be furious with him.
He has brought shame upon the House of Yuan with such conduct.
Does Yuan Shu hold a grudge against him?
Hmm.
There's nothing in particular that I'm aware of.
There may be a simpler explanation, for instance.
Perhaps he feels he was deprived of his moment of glory.
If that is the case, then his actions are even more unforgivable.
All of us almost lost our lives.
Lord Sun Jian is fuming about this incident.
Yeah, nobody died.
I can't wait for my History of the Romance of the Two Kingdoms, guys.
Nobody important died, everybody.
We were defending the stronghold.
There wasn't time to think about those who rushed barashly out to the front line.
Rushed out?
We may have pushed the vanguard, but we didn't plan to go that far from the stronghold.
Yeah, the characters are gonna age as we play longer.
That's why they have no mustaches.
That's why they're babies with no mustaches.
Lord Yuan Shu, let me be very clear.
This is the longest Sun Jian has ever lived for in like 8 games.
I haven't fucking seen Sun Jian live this long in a long time.
If you want to live, that is.
Damn, that's fucked.
Um, excuse me, he is a tiger.
At best, he's gonna meow.
Oh my god, he is alive!
Yes, that was quite the mark you made.
Guan Yu and Zhang Fei, you two as well.
They weren't even in the final battle.
You guys died to one man.
They seem to have trouble with cohesion.
Cohesion?
It was one guy!
Lord Yuan Shu, arguing during the battle.
And while you'll see some troops praise each other's power, others are berating their ostensible allies over their ancestors.
That had no name!
The worst part is that general had no name!
It's hard to imagine things working out.
It is easy to say we're fighters united for a cause, but we must remember that we each have our own motivations.
There are those concerned about the way of the world, those moved by call to act, and those who want to take Dong Zhuo's place.
They squabble simply because they each have a different end goal in mind.
Hey, come on!
What's with all this depressing talk, huh?
We won, didn't we?
We?
Where's the we?
You guys only were alive for like 15% of that fight!
You're right, Zhang Fei.
And I really should learn from your outline.
Where did the we came from?
Let us rest and prepare for the next battle.
I don't know about this we business here.
But you're a sworn fourth brother, Doki!
Oh, shit!
There's the battle right there!
Oh, fuck!
There it is!
Battle of Hulao Gate!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Oh my god, we have a fan!
Ye olde dragoon!
Oh, I learned a new tactic.
Oh my god, guys!
I'm making my own dragoon army right now!
Oh my god, who wants to join the dragoons, guys?
Okay, there's nothing new here, though.
Oh, what's this?
I haven't unlocked this yet?
Yeah, I have.
New tactics can be swapped?
Oh, I can swap tactics.
More fodder to feed Lu Bu.
I have no idea who Yuan Zhen is.
Is he new?
But would you accept this?
I don't know this guy.
Join me, brothers!
So we can pursue Lu Bu!
I don't know who this guy is.
Alright, let me pay my relationship therapist.
Real quick, guys.
Can I join after you beat- No!
You can only join when we're fighting Lu Bu.
That's the true dedication.
Okay, I guess I pay him.
Yay!
My bond grows stronger!
Okay, Li Dian...
Chen Gong...
and then...
Okay, I need to get Chen Gong, Xiaodong, and Li Dian.
Okay, where are they, though?
Wait, where are they?
They're in the Yang province.
Okay, I need to talk to them in Yang province.
See, I want to make sure there's no extra stuff here.
Okay, I need to go to Yang province.
Yang...
Li...
Dian...
Ji...
Yu...
Jin...
The fuck is that?
Yang province!
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Wait, do I not have- Okay, there he is.
Yu Jin was Cao Cao's best general.
He won every battle he was in, but last- Wait, how come I've never heard of him before?
How come he- Was he ever a character before?
Alright, it's time to go on a date.
Finally.
I can get rid of- I finally got rid of Diao Chan.
Oh, it was me?
I knew paying the relationship therapist would work.
Did something happen?
Finally!
What we're here for!
Poetry, okay.
Wow, that's so romantic.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
Oh man.
What do you think?
It'll be hot if I'm interested in poetry?
Or do you think it'll be like, that's so hot that you don't care?
Oh no.
Oh, these are actual- Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
Guys, what do you guys think?
How do you know if I'm in or not?
I'm not into it?
Okay, we can't fumble here, guys!
Guys, we can't fumble it!
Two?
Not suited- it's so hard.
Okay.
I'm not suited for poetry.
Oh, think we're relatable!
Oh my god, things are relatable!
I made him laugh, guys.
I'm in.
I like how I just invited myself to sit with him.
Oh my god, he's brooding.
Oh, that's so hot.
That seems exciting.
That's so hot, bro.
We can learn poetry together.
Maybe I'll enjoy fighting more if you fall on side with me.
I'll think about it.
I'm in!
I'm so in!
I'm so good at everything, guys!
It's really hard to get.
Bro, I don't even need to try to risk the girls.
The girls don't even give me an option.
It's like, yes or yes.
But when I talk to the guys, I actually have to think about my responses.
Even when I say no to the girls, the girls give me another choice and be like, you can't say no.
You have to say yes.
Like, the girls have like zero options.
Like, I don't even need to try.
There's no challenge.
There's actually no challenge when I talk to the girls.
Tell him he's the apple of your eye.
Avoid Don.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, there you go.
There's Chen Gong.
Roses are red.
Violets are blue.
Doki Bird must not pursue Lu Bu.
Claude, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Avoid Don.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tell him he's the apple of your eye.
It's me.
They say you're a warrior who sells your skills with blade.
I have a request for you.
You accept it, won't you?
Prevention of... I don't care about Chen Gong enough.
Let's just go to Hulao Gate.
We'll do his quest later.
Where's Hulao Gate?
Oh, Hulao Gate is right there.
Oh my god, look at all the poets in the chat.
I got another old coin.
Wait, what?
I joined TaoTao for Cheng He?
I was not... he spent the night in my bed?
Wait, really?
What?
I did not know that was possible.
Wait, what?
Wait, is that true?
Oh, wow.
To be fair, Guan Yu invited us to his bed.
Yes, I say us.
We were all there.
Alright, it's time to pursue Lu Bu, guys.
It's fucking time.
Just the two of us.
We were all there.
There's an enormous structure that provides a strong defensive position for Dong Zhuo.
Yet, place his forces there to make it stand.
When the enemy stands before us, waiting to be defeated, we'll crush them with our combined forces.
Our interim leader is the pillar holding up the coalition.
We must beware not to allow the enemy to reach our headquarters.
I'll now give each of you your orders.
I can confirm.
Cheng He and I read Tao Tao's poems in the same bed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, you know, that's what bro-homies do.
That's what the bros do.
Read each other poems, guys.
You read your bro.
You'd read a poem for your bro, right?
Concentrating our forces in front of the gate will be essential.
Every army should start the battle by heading for that position.
Our forces will approach from all directions to eliminate the troops guarding the gate and every group to begin our final assault on Dong Zhuo.
We have now prepared Taobots for our siege.
If we use them well, they will make short work of the gate's defenses.
But Hu Lao's gate is not the only arrow in Dong Zhuo's quiver.
He also has the peerless warrior Lu Bu, a man with power enough to turn the tide of the battle on his own.
We cannot be sure what he will do, so we will have to be ready for anything.
But take care of that.
My men and I will keep that demon from wreaking too much havoc.
I see that Lu Bei's forces are at your command, Lord Zhang.
How formidable.
Very well.
Take up the rearguard.
Loyal subjects of the Han, this is where we bury the evil Dong Zhuo.
Seize this victory and restore order to the realm!
Nice, I have Xiaohu Dun with me.
This is where he loses his eye, guys.
It's gonna be so cool.
Me and my homies with our poetry stand.
Alright, guys.
It's time.
We go this way?
I don't know.
I'm just gonna go down.
Get over there.
Open that gate.
Darkblade, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I volunteer as the Joji Dragon Warrior.
Please don't kill me.
Guys, we all have to work together to defeat Lu Bu, guys.
This is a team effort.
You're not just gonna ditch me, right?
When we fight Lu Bu?
Guys, if we throw enough men into Lu Bu, he'll surely die, right?
Right, guys?
Surely he'll get tired.
He'll get tired eventually, right?
Right, guys?
Eventually.
Okay, eat your bread.
Eat your bread.
I can take him.
Okay, nice.
Broke it.
I'm close!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Poetry Slam with the homies.
But it's not the poetry getting slammed.
Oh my god.
Poetry and chill.
Before Netflix was born, me and my homies used to do poetry and slam.
Such great strength.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
What the fuck is going on?
Damn, bro.
Changiao!
Oh my god.
Wait, is a duel of pikes good against Lu Bu?
Me and Lu.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
Holy shit.
Okay, I told you guys, right?
My like... I had a crush on Changiao.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
Ma Chao.
Oh shit.
Okay, guys.
I can't.
Sorry, guys.
I need to focus right now.
He is very, very strong.
Did you call Lu Bu?
Before they made him a baby face?
And then I was like, oh my god, he's ugly now.
Oh my god, he's a baby now.
I can't.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, what the?
Oh fuck.
Oh my god, what the fuck am I supposed to do?
Oh, I don't have any bread left.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, I might actually die.
Guys, I can't.
I can't.
I can't focus.
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
My heart.
My heart is beating.
Guys, I actually might die.
Oh my- He's so strong!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Holy shit, he's so- Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, guys.
I don't know if I can beat Lu Bu.
I can't even beat his fucking minion.
Holy shit.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna full focus.
I'm gonna full focus right now.
Okay, we got full focus here.
Jesus Christ, he was so strong.
I can't even defeat his henchman.
I don't know if I can defeat Lu Bu.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Bam.
Alright, there he's gonna come over now.
Okay, I'm scared, guys.
I'm so scared.
Oh, I have to lock in.
I actually have to lock in.
Alright, I'ma lock in right here.
Nice.
Ooh!
Okay.
Like, when he does his dash, it's so scary.
His dash is so scary.
Holy shit, his dash does the most damage.
I need to, like, be able to- Oh my god, what the fuck?
Whoa!
Oh god!
Oh, I just have to jump!
Jesus Christ.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I broke his shield.
Okay, I'm going full focus.
Guys, I have to defeat his fucking henchman first before we pursue Lu Bu.
Oh, I fucked up the arrow!
Okay, I'm gonna take him to the arrow, guys.
Guys, I fucked up.
I fucked up the arrow.
Oh, whoops.
God, fuck!
Okay, nice.
Oh, I'm focusing so hard right now.
Nice!
Counter!
Okay.
He's so close to dying.
Please, he's one hit!
He's one hit!
Nice!
Counter!
That's right!
Oh my god, I got the pike.
Oh, that is so fucking intense.
Alright, but yes.
Okay, here was my list when I was younger.
When I was a little bird.
It was like Cheng Liao, Ma Chao, because he was so fucking cool with his helmet.
Zhuge Liang.
Lu Bei, before I realized, he was just like, he was like, you know...
How do I explain him?
He was like, all talk, but like a failure as a person.
And then they shaved off his mustache, and I was like, oh man, he's a fucking baby.
Like...
Ma Chao was a monster IRL, but he looked cool!
But he looked so cool!
It is not my fault that they, like, um, um, what's his name?
Oh my god.
It was not my fault that, oh my god, who is, what's the poster child's name again?
Fuck, is it Cheng Liao?
Okay, it's, it's, oh my god.
Oh my god, I already forgot his name because he hasn't appeared in so long.
Zhao Yun, it's not my fault that, like, after Zhao Yun, they, Ma Chao was like the second poster child.
I don't know if you guys remember that, but if they can't use Zhao Yun, they use Ma Chao.
Because he looked so cool, okay?
Zhao, Ma Chao was like the second poster child after Zhao Yun.
And, like, I honestly thought he was cooler than Zhao Yun, um, the way they made his design.
Anyway, look, he might be a monster IRL, but, like, but he was so cool though.
Yeah, um, okay.
And then, no, I think Xiao Hu Dan was the third poster.
I think, I think the rankings was, um, Zhao Yun, Ma Chao, and then Xiao Hu Dan.
I think that was, like, the ranking, rankings of, like, how, like, the, the, the preferential treatment that they gave the characters.
Um, and then everybody else was, like, whatever.
But, like, those were my favorite characters.
Okay, well, thank God.
Thank God he's fucking dead.
Holy shit, he was so scary.
Okay, is this, is this weapon strong?
I don't know if this weapon is strong.
Which is stronger?
For Lu Bu.
Which one should I use against Lu Bu?
The Pykes or the, um...
I don't know which is stronger.
Is this stronger than the, uh, is this better for, oh shit.
Is this better against Lu Bu?
Guys, I need to know which one's better against Lu Bu, guys.
Because, like, we are at Hulao Gate right now.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus, what?!
How am I not there?!
Okay, nice.
Jesus Christ, they're all so strong.
Who do I have to help?
Jesus Christ, how are you guys?
Okay, we gotta go up.
Okay.
The strongest weapon against Lu Bu is surrender.
We will pursue Lu Bu.
Please, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over as fast as I can.
Okay, I'm ready.
Wait, you guys won.
Wait, what the fuck?
I didn't even have to be there.
Wait, what?
What?
I didn't even have to be there.
Oh my god, they all did it.
What was the point of me being here?
I guess I can take this gate, though.
Okay.
I still don't know which- Oh wait, I should've- Actually, I just remembered.
I should've- I forgot to put something for this.
Oh wait, we should get the fire arrows.
Okay.
Oh damn it, I can't- It's so hard to do counters for this one.
Okay, nice.
I don't know what I did.
Was that the counter?
Did I do the counter?
I can't tell!
This is my first time with the Pykes!
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, it's someone's birthday?
Okay, I wish them happy birthday after I kill Lu Bu.
Don't worry.
Your birthday gift is me killing Lu Bu.
Oh.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, we're getting closer.
We're getting closer to Hulao Gate, guys.
We're almost there.
Wait, where?
So many gates.
Nice.
Come on.
Come on!
I wanna beat Xiaohu Du!
Oh shit!
Nice.
Okay.
My only goal is to beat Xiaohu Du!
God, I'm so scared.
We're getting closer and closer to Lu Bu.
No way out.
You'll only get your happy birthday until we beat Lu Bu.
I don't know.
I can't get the timing for the counter right with the Peek Pykes.
It's so weird.
Oh fuck!
I actually used my circle!
God damn it.
The Pyke is so hard to do the...
do the counter.
It's like... it's such a weird... I don't know.
It's such a weird timing for this one.
Yeah, he's almost dead though.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Oh, I can climb up?
Oh my god.
How do I do it?
Wait, where is he?
Who am I protecting?
Where is he?
Wait, what the fuck?
How am I so far away?
This weapon is so long!
How did I miss?
He's right next to me!
That doesn't make sense!
I don't know how I could miss.
Like, he was right there.
How did I miss?
He was right there.
I don't understand.
Oh my god!
Changmiao, please, for the love of god!
Changmiao, please!
Eat your bread!
Oh, thank god!
I was like... it was like pure cinema.
Holy shit, that was actual pure cinema, guys.
He was one hit from, like, dying and I got in there and he ate his bread.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
I'm actually a hero.
He's coming!
I hear him!
Oh no!
Oh, I'm scared!
Oh my god, he already killed a man!
What the fuck?
What do you mean two already died?
Three died?
Okay, I'm fucking...
Guys, I don't... guys, I can't... I'm not good with the twin peak, I've realized.
Where is he?
Oh shit!
There he is!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
He's just...
Bro, he's just on his horse!
You can't even get him off his horse!
Bro!
Like, how do I get him off his horse?
No!
That's so fun!
He doesn't even get off his horse!
I'm just gonna kill this guy.
Okay, let me just kill him.
Let me just...
Let me just feel good.
Okay.
Bro, he doesn't even get off his horse!
He pays one red hair!
Okay.
Okay, guys, someone get him off his horse and then maybe I can help you.
And then maybe I can do something.
Oh shit!
Wait, can I actually get him off his horse?
Oh my god, someone!
Oh my god!
He's still on his horse!
Wait, I got an idea!
Shao Chun!
This is it!
I might...
Oh my god, maybe this is not it.
This is it.
Maybe we can do this, Shao Chun!
Maybe we can do this together!
Maybe it's just...
Oh my god, we got him off his horse!
Let's go!
With the power of Shao Chun, he got back on his horse?!
That should be illegal!
What?!
No!
He just ran away!
That's not fair!
He just ran!
Bro!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm like one third!
Like, I'm only one third!
Like, what do I do?!
Bro!
I have buns left!
I don't have any buns left, guys!
Bro!
Oh my god, I got him off my horse!
Guys!
I got one third!
Guys, I did it!
It's...
Guys...
Guys, I don't know if I can kill a little fella, guys!
Guys, it's not fair!
He's on his horse!
He's not even...
Like, how is this fair?!
Like, what the fuck?!
Like, he's just on his horse!
Oh my god, I got him off his horse, though.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's Sierra's.
Goodbye!
Like, he just called his horse back and that should be so illegal!
Like, he just gets on his horse?!
How could they let him do that?!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god.
How did he beat somebody that's just on his horse?!
Nobody warned me about Lu Bu's horse to ground missile.
Like, what the fuck?!
Jesus Christ!
Jesus!
Here we go!
Fire arrows!
There's no way he's gonna move, right?!
He just gets back on it!
That should be so illegal!
Like, who gave...
This should be like, Final Destination, no horses!
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, the missile!
The fucking missile!
Bro!
It's not fair!
He sends a missile!
Okay.
What do you mean?!
You work for me, Dracos!
What do you mean you're gonna run?!
We're in this together!
Oh my god, even you guys left me.
That's so fucked.
You wanted me to fucking...
You wanted me to kill Lu Bu and you run away?!
The fuck happened?!
Oh my god.
What the fuck?!
I don't know if I'm doing anything.
I feel like I'm just...
I don't know that I do anything?!
Oh my god!
We got to phase 2!
Oh, fuck!
Guys, we got to phase 2 though!
Jesus Christ.
Holy fuck.
We're spirits are aroused!
Okay, nice.
Oh, nice!
Okay.
We're back here.
It did not check point.
But like, fuck me I guess.
Nice.
Oh my god, please!
No!
Fuck!
Oh my god, you left again?!
No!
It's so hard!
Oh my god, it's so difficult!
We will... we can do this, guys.
We can kill Lu Bu!
No!
Oh my god!
Please, stop resisting!
Stop resisting, I'm here for peace!
Stop resisting!
This is for peace!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, fuck!
Oh no, he's doing his fucking nuclear bomb!
Jesus.
No, I dodged it.
You fucking coward, Chat.
Okay.
Bro, he just keeps running now!
Yes, I did the perfect dodge.
Okay.
Okay, I got him off!
Okay, he's almost at half HP, guys!
I almost got him to half HP!
I hate him.
He just rides away.
I hate him so much.
Okay, nice.
Oh, fuck!
Am I... what am I doing?
Where am I?
Okay, phase two.
Oh my god, no!
Oh
my god, why don't I have a checkpoint for phase two?
Oh my...
Holy shit.
I feel like I should have a... I feel like I should have a checkpoint for phase two.
This shit... this shit is so fucked up.
Oh my god.
Please!
I'm standing you as much as I can!
Okay, I'm gonna get more buns right here.
JK.
Nice!
Perfect dodge.
Okay, I'm figuring out his patterns, guys.
Oh, fuck!
Guys, I'll be right back.
Guys, don't die.
There's buns right here, guys.
Don't die, guys.
Gotta find the buns.
Wait, where's the buns?
There it is.
Okay, I refilled.
Alright, I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
This is not cheating!
Guys, it's fucking Lu Bu, guys!
It's not cheating!
It's literally Lu Bu!
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
I got buns now!
That's right!
Get buns!
I can do this.
Oh my god, he's too far away.
I can't break dance near him.
No, he's too far away!
He's too far away from my break dance!
Wait, this is possible.
Wait, oh my god.
I'm sorry, I got too cocky.
Oh my god, I got too cocky.
Maybe not.
I didn't remember to die.
Oh my god!
Why can't I...
Can you not counter him?
Can you not counter?
Oh my... wait.
No!
Oh my god.
I thought I could counter him.
I didn't realize it's uncounterable.
Okay, okay.
Oh, you can?
Okay, clearly I don't know how.
Oh, I fucked up my arrow.
The first time.
Wait, did he just... what the fuck, he just ran off.
Wait, he just ran so far.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I'm gonna get him.
Okay, that's fine.
No, I used the right... fuck, okay.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine, I got him off the horse.
Oh, I got him off the horse, that's okay.
Woo!
Okay, that's fine, that's fine.
This is fine, this is fine, we're all okay.
We got him off the horse.
Okay, after this I'm gonna get bread.
Okay, goodbye.
Oh, phase two.
Phase two, I get bread now.
Phase two is bread time.
I believe in them for surviving a little longer when I get the bread.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
I just needed to grab bread.
It's fine.
Please, this is important.
We're gonna kill Lu Bu.
Okay, Cao Cao's dead, but we're gonna kill him though.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Jesus Christ, I can't dodge it!
He does like two attacks!
Come on.
What the fuck?!
I- I can't!
I can't dodge it!
I like- how do I dodge that?
Like, I can do this dodge?!
Jesus Christ!
I don't know how to dodge that!
Oh!
Dodge one parry or block?
Is that how you do it?
I think he's gonna come this way.
Okay, he did.
Wait, oh my god!
Okay, yeah man, that was a really good prediction though.
Oh my- okay, that prediction was crazy, yeah man.
That was an insane prediction I had there.
Are you serious?!
Guys, I don't know, guys.
Guys, I don't know anymore.
Guys, I don't know anymore, guys!
This horse is so buff!
Guys, I don't know anymore.
This horse is so fucking strong!
Why?!
This horse is so strong, guys!
I don't know!
I'm so scared!
Oh my god, I perfectly- Oh my- what the- Okay, okay, I have- Where is he?
Please get over here.
Please, let me breakdance on you really fast!
Oh man, I broke his shit.
I can stun him.
Oh my god, I'm halfway through.
Goodbye.
I leave, I leave, I leave, I leave, I need to get bread.
I leave.
Goodbye.
It's bread time.
I leave, I leave.
Bread time!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, let's go back.
His phase 2 is so hard!
Oh my god, I'm coming back!
Oh my god!
Okay.
What?!
I just got here!
I'm so fucked up!
I only just got here!
Jesus, don't- Get out of here!
Get out of here!
No!
Bro!
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad!
Oh my god, why is he so strong?!
Oh my god, that was my best run.
That was my best run so far.
Oh fuck, I fucked up.
Or did I?
I got him off his horse.
So did I really fucked up?
I did though, I did.
I fucked up there.
Jesus.
Like, I figured out how to dodge that, but like his regular attacks is so- His regular attacks is really scary.
Like his regular attacks is actually so scary.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, more full focus guys.
Nice, I dodged it.
Okay, we gotta get him to phase 2 and we get bread.
The moment we get him to phase 2, we get bread.
Cool.
No!
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Okay, full focus, full focus.
Okay.
I just don't know how to- I don't know how to do the- his like normal attacks.
His normal attacks is so hard to dodge.
Okay, I have three buns.
Okay, okay, okay.
We can do this, we can do this, we can defeat Lupu.
There's like four of us.
Surely we can kill him.
Bread?
Like, how do you dodge that?
I need a perfect dodge that, but oh my god!
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Like, what?!
I don't know what to do!
You have to do perfect evades, that's so hard!
Okay.
Like, I can do this, this one's easy.
That one I can do.
That one I know how to do the perfect dodge.
Parry his first attack.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Come on!
Oh!
Nice!
I'm stunning him.
This is the most I've ever done.
Perfect.
Oh my god!
Jesus!
No!
Bread, bread, bread, bread, bread, bread, bread, bread, bread!
Bread, bread, bread, bread, bread!
That was the best I've ever done for the first phase.
Oh, I got the bread.
I got the bread.
I got the bakery.
Oh!
I got the bread, guys, I got the bread!
Okay, back to hell.
What the fuck?!
Back to hell I go!
Oh my god, it's more than halfway!
More than halfway!
What is this?!
I'm breakdancing.
Okay, lock in, lock in.
Lock in, Doki.
No!
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
Get over here.
Oh my god, I'm parried!
Oh my god!
No!
Oh, I parried, I parried for the first time!
No, and then I stopped parrying!
Oh my god, is there any more bread?
Guys, guys, we're gonna run for bread!
Guys, we have to leave!
We'll be back, we'll be back, we'll be back, we'll be back, we'll be back, we'll be back!
We gotta go grab some bread!
We'll be back, we'll be back!
Oh my god, there's bread!
There's bread!
Second bread run!
Don't worry, we're back!
We're coming back!
We're coming back for the fight!
Guys, this isn't cheating!
It's literally Lu Bu!
Guys, this is different.
It's Lu Bu.
You'd understand.
It's literally Lu Bu.
Oh my god.
Guys...
I don't...
Wait!
Oh my god!
Checkpoint!
Wait, when are you being a gun?
Wait!
Guys, I got a checkpoint!
Oh my god, I got a checkpoint!
There's actually a gun!
This is so doable!
Oh, fuck!
Nevermind.
Nevermind, he decided to bring a gun.
Wait, unless...
Okay.
JK.
Oh, I missed.
That's cool.
Okay.
Oh, I countered.
Oh my god, I countered.
Oh my god, what world am I living in where I actually countered?
Oh my god, I died.
I died.
Oh my god, he's so low!
He's right there!
Perfect!
Perfect invade!
Oh my god!
No!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
It's fine.
Just kill Xiaodong, I don't care.
You can kill him!
I just need to live.
Oh, my heart.
Oh, perfect!
Okay, that was a little overkill.
That was... Guys, I can't get bread!
I've used up all the bread!
I've actually used up all my bread resources!
Oh, I have to avoid that?
Okay.
Okay!
Oh, thank god!
Xiaodong focused defenses!
I'm 1 HP!
Oh,
fuck!
Got it!
Oh, fuck!
No!
Wait!
It was so good!
I just...
Oh my god, it was so good!
I got so many dodges!
Oh my god, I did so many perfect MPs!
It was so cool!
It was so fucking cool!
No!
It was so cool!
I did such... Oh my god!
The perfect MPs and everything!
Oh my god!
I actually landed every dodge possible!
And I still fumbled it!
I still fumbled it!
I landed every fucking dodge imaginable!
Okay.
Oh my... Guys, I know it's cheesy that I am...
That, like, we're doing checkpoints, but you don't understand.
I'm a broken man now.
I'm so broken.
I can't... I cannot do... I cannot, like, 100-0 Lu Bu.
You don't understand.
I've been through so much.
You did Lu Bu.
You don't understand.
He's... He's... He's a fucking monster!
He is the hardest man you will ever fight.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god!
Holy shit.
Okay.
I'm sorry, Toki!
I'm sorry!
I'm fighting Lu Bu right now!
I have to fight Lu Bu!
No!
I'm locking in.
I have to lock... I'm locking in.
Okay, kill him.
Kill him.
Not me.
Alright, there you go.
My turn.
Okay, I guess not.
My turn for real, though.
For real.
Okay.
Oh my god!
I won it again!
Oh my...
Okay, actually locked in.
I'm actually locked in for real.
Okay, kill him.
That's fine.
Oh god.
What?
How do I... Oh my god.
Are you serious?!
Okay, that is bullshit.
Like, I should be able to counter that!
Why can't I fucking invade that?
Come on!
Okay, I'm just gonna dodge further away.
Nice!
What?!
I don't know.
I can't get past his first attack anymore.
Okay.
Nice!
Alright.
We can do this.
Oh my god!
Nice.
Okay.
I'm degrading!
I'm getting worse!
How am I getting worse?!
Okay.
Okay, no part.
Focus.
Guys.
Okay.
I'm losing focus.
Okay, calm down.
Calm down, Doki.
You got this.
I don't have arrows, guys.
Guys, I don't have arrows.
I have it on cooldown.
Wait, do I actually?
I can't, guys.
I can't arrow.
It's on cooldown.
Oh my god!
What happened to me?!
Okay, stop.
Stop mauling.
You're only losing because you're getting mad now.
You're only losing because you're angry.
Which is understandable.
He's noobu.
This can't be.
Okay.
Okay, we got this.
Don't maul.
And then we... dodge!
Okay.
Focus.
Be patient.
Be patient, Doki.
Alright.
Are you serious?!
I've got no choice but to fall back.
Concentrate.
I can't die in a place like this.
I'll allow others to take the glory today.
Okay.
Oh my god!
I did it!
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it!
We fucking did it.
Oh, my voice is gone, but we killed littlebu.
We did it.
We pursued littlebu.
We fucking did it.
We fucking pursued littlebu.
I'm so happy.
Everybody is dead.
Everyone is dead, but we did it.
We did it.
I'm sorry.
They're all dead, but we did it, though.
They're all dead, but we did it.
I don't care.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
I don't care.
I don't care if we used the checkpoint.
It would have been impossible to kill him.
Guys, you don't understand.
I would be here forever if I didn't use checkpoint.
I wouldn't have, we would have not ended stream for a long time.
I'm just so happy.
I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
We pursued Lu Bu.
Everyone is dead, but we did it.
They're all dead.
All our friends are dead.
But it's okay.
Lu Bu is dead.
He's dead.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm so happy.
It's okay, me and Lu Bu, we can solo this.
We can solo this, me and Lu Bu.
It's alright, alright Lu Bu, just you and I.
Let's go.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
I'm so happy.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, what do I do against the catapults?
What the fuck?
What do I do here?
Okay.
Okay, guys, please.
Please get out.
I'm so... I'm just...
Oh my god, I don't care if I die here.
Soldiers are strong, but you can bring down it by striking them from behind?
How do I...
How?
This way!
Wait, how?
Oh my god!
Is this how I'm gonna die?
Oh my...
Guys, this is how I'm gonna die.
I guess.
I guess this is how I'm gonna...
How do I... What?
How do I pass through them?
Wait, there's...
There's buttons here.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna figure this out.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna do this.
That's fine.
I'm just gonna... Fuck yeah, I'm just gonna run straight at it.
I'm fine with that.
Wait, I can just jump... Guys, you liars.
Guys, I can't just jump through it.
Guys, you liars.
Guys, I have an idea.
The only way.
I shall shout, who turned my way out of here.
I shall shout, who turned my way...
Nothing beats shout, who turned...
I shall shout, who turned my way out...
That's fucking right.
How do I destroy it though?
Oh.
Wait, a fire attack?
Oh shit, wait, I was supposed to...
That's fine.
Wait, I wasn't supposed to do that.
Oh well.
Oh, I need allies.
Whoops.
I just realized this is not how you're supposed to win this.
Okay, I forgot about my allies, guys.
It's fine.
I created an opening.
But I have an opening though.
But look at this cool ass opening I made.
For my team.
Okay, let's like, help them.
Um, okay, this is awkward.
How do I...
Okay, we gotta figure this out.
My openings are really tiny.
This is...
Look at that tiny opening I made though!
Look at that!
Look at the opening!
Alright guys, I don't think we're defeating the caterpillar anytime soon.
Oh my god, what do you mean, Dragoon?!
What do you... Oh my god, my Dragoons don't believe in me.
I don't understand.
Dragoons, why don't you believe?!
Sorry, we got hit by the caterpillar.
I'm doing my best!
Fuck this.
Fuck this one guy!
Nice!
Go Lupe!
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Nice, I broke his neck!
Guys, come on!
We just need to break two caterpillars, guys!
I created an opening!
What else do you want me to do?!
Okay, I gotta kill him first before I do anything.
Nice.
Alright.
Guys, guys, come on!
Let's kill this caterpillar!
Come on!
We did it!
Guys, we're doing it!
I do not have enough allies.
I don't have enough allies!
Guys, we got this!
The last caterpillar!
Please!
Please, guys!
We can do this!
We can do this in 44 seconds!
It's just the four brothers.
Guys, we can do this!
Look at the underhull I made!
We did it!
I understood the assignments, guys.
I definitely understood.
It's just me and Shu.
It is a little awkward that it's just me and Shu because I let everybody else die for Lu Bu.
But you don't understand.
It was very important.
You guys don't understand.
Wait, again?
Oh my god.
Okay, where's my other opening?
Wait, there it is.
I was like, where's the other opening that I made?
It's okay, we did it.
I knew that would be important.
Guys, I knew that would have been important.
There it is.
Zhang Fei, please.
Wait, what?
Wait, Dao Chen!
What happened?
Oh no.
Please, I have to do this first.
I have to kill him.
No way, you mean the girl that ends up marrying Lu Bu and...
Lu Bu and... Oh my god, Dao Chen.
Okay, who dueled me?
You're dueling me, you bitch.
You bitch.
That's right.
You think you're gonna win this 1v1?
You think you're gonna win this?
That's fucking right.
That's right.
You're not gonna win shit.
Get out of here.
Get out.
Okay, where is he?
Alright, back to the real fight.
Get out.
Get out of here.
Fucking challenging me.
Can't believe you think you're gonna win this fight.
That's embarrassing.
That's so... Eat your puns.
Guys, I feel like I might crash when I hit a thousandth kill.
Guys, if my PC crashes the moment we hit a thousand kills, I'm ending stream.
We're getting there, guys.
And I'm afraid.
I am very afraid.
We are a hundred away.
I'm calling it.
I can't have nice things.
I'm fucking calling it.
And then we have to fight him again.
Okay, do I get to save my game?
Is there a save?
There's no saves.
You can't save in the battle.
It's getting there.
Natalie took everything from me.
Okay, let's get Li Ming out of here too.
Do I not?
Okay, I do.
Okay.
Okay, I knew there was gonna be arrows.
Nice.
I broke his shield.
There's always an opening.
Fifty more to go.
Fifty more.
Oh my god, I almost forgot to eat that bun.
Okay.
Jesus, Chris, I did not mean to call my horse.
Why are you so strong?
You are no... I literally killed Dil Chen in like 30 seconds.
You should not be that strong.
Get out.
Wait, bro, he's 1 HP.
You are not kill-stealing that from me.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm scared.
Guys.
Mr. Boi!
Oh no!
No, he's so far!
Jesus Christ, 90!
A thousand.
I am a true warrior.
I am a true warrior!
Am I still a true warrior?
I am still a true warrior!
We live!
We're living!
You know what?
Fuck this.
Oh, I don't have enough allies.
Oh my god, we actually lived.
Oh my god.
I don't... I forgot what that was like.
Also, I'm fucking 2v1-ing right now.
This is so not fair.
Bro, okay.
Okay, I don't have any more bread.
I'm leaving.
Wait, are there any bread?
Okay, guys, I have to get the bread right here.
Me and the shoe army.
It's literally just me and the shoe army in this fight.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Go, go, go, go.
Xiaohu Dan is not okay right now.
None of us are okay.
Jesus Christ.
Don't worry, I'm pretty sure Zhang Fei will be okay.
Don't worry.
Alright.
Come on, run into my blades.
Nice.
Alright.
Zhang Fei will be okay.
He has enough bread to sustain himself.
He has so much bread to sustain himself.
I'm gonna save... I'm saving my... my musu for Dong Zhuo.
Lupe, please.
Wait, does Lupe not have any more bread?
Oh no, Lupe doesn't have any more bread.
Lupe, no!
Okay.
This should be the last one.
He makes me wanna buy bread.
Oh my god, it's time!
It's time!
It's time to be angry!
I'm ready!
I'm ready to be mad!
That's fucking right, I'll break that thing on you!
I'm coming over.
Fucking coming over.
Get out of here!
Fucking what?
Get in there, Lupe!
Nice.
That's right!
It's unlocked!
Lupe has trained me for this!
That's right, get countered!
Lupe has not trained me for this, but still get countered.
Lupe has not taught me how to counter.
Yes!
I challenge you.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Oh, you thought... you thought just cause you're gonna do a 1v1?
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
You think I won?
You're gonna win a 1v1?
Oh shit.
Sorry.
Okay, I still got it.
I still got it.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry, I just wanted to make him feel...
Guys, guys, don't worry.
I still got it.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, everything is still fine.
I just wanted to make him feel a little special.
I got a little cocky.
The fucking guy.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh my god.
That was the hardest.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
Bro, there's no way I don't get his health.
That was definitely the hardest.
Oh my god.
I leveled up so much.
Level 11.
I think I spent an hour on that fucking fight alone.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I earned so much because of it.
Holy shit, look at everything I completed.
I should have enough.
I have 179.
Jesus.
Okay, we need attack.
We need defense.
We need health.
That was actually... I had to solo a fucking war.
I let everybody die.
Okay.
That had to be... had to be the hardest fight of my fucking life.
And I'm gonna call it there.
Oh my god.
I felt like I was clawing my way to victory.
Guys, I have no voice anymore.
I have no voice anymore.
Lupo took everything from me.
He took everything.
I can't talk anymore.
Guys, I know I used checkpoints, but you don't understand.
If I didn't use checkpoints, that fight would single-handedly take me nine hours.
I could feel it.
I could feel that fight taking me nine hours to beat for Lupo alone.
I'm sorry, I'll feed you.
I had to fight Lupo.
You don't understand, Toki.
I had to fight.
Like, I don't... I'm hungry.
Oh, I gotta call it here.
He hungry.
But thank you everybody for coming.
I pursued Lupo.
Everybody, thank you all for watching me pursue Lupo.
It was quite a journey.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!